lionel petits pas bonjour merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
pour commencer votre engagement
il est venu de quoi vous avez perdu une
personne
une personne proche du coc vide oui
bonjour bonjour à vous deux oui mais mon
épouse mon épouse a décidé d'essayer de
la colline le 29 mars 2022
les partis en ambulance le 23 mars à 23
heures et je n'ai plus jamais revu ni
vivante ni défunte et donc vous demander
aujourd'hui à ce que le président
organise une journée de commémoration
pour les victimes du coc vide on n'a pas
beaucoup vu nous ces images évidemment
ceux qui n'ont pas été confrontées à
cette maladie
c'est une période qui a été extrêmement
difficile mais bien sûr le fait de ne
pas pouvoir accompagner son défunt comme
le rite funéraire le doigt dans nos
sociétés c'est extrêmement difficile
pour pour autant le deuil est toujours
pas fait puisqu'on est toujours dans
cette dans cette perspective de d'avoir
laissé partir nous dépeint comme des
comme des pestiférés sans accompagnement
et sont ils sont partis sans aucun
respect sans aucune dignité sans aucune
reconnaissance et le fait de demander
cet hommage national c'est pour combler
ce manque et cet hommage de la sonal
bien sûr qu'il ait décrété par le
président de la république mais c'est
également la nation qui se doit de
redonner de redonner à ces déchets ce
qui leur a manqué lors de lors de leur
décès parce qu'une cérémonie d'hommage
permettra en premier lieu ce que vous
nous dites c'est de permettre aux
familles de faire leur deuil ce qui n'a
pas pu être possible lors de cette
pandémie que tu as fait tout à fait les
les familles ont été totalement exclu
totalement oubliés du système on va dire
un simplement pour votre information
aucune aucune aucun accompagnement
psychologique aucun numéro téléphone
nous a été communiquée pour qu'on puisse
avoir un accompagnement suite assez
difficile des femmes c'est difficile
décès pardon et donc forcément
les familles sont centrés sont très
touchés par rapport aux conditions dans
lesquelles c'est arrivé
on n'a pas pu on n'a pas pu accompagner
nos défunts on n'a pas la paye de
toilette mortuaire de fait ils sont
partis nous enfermer dans une housse en
plastique mis dans un cercueil est parti
à la crémation le plus rapidement
possible dans quand même aucun
accompagnement la france qui a dépassé
la barre des 80 mille morts
le président de la république parle de
guerre nous peut-être que la logique de
cette journée de commémoration selon
vous est ce que vous êtes en relation
avec d'autres familles justement qui
sont dans le même cas que vous bien sûr
au niveau de l'association j'ai reçu
beaucoup de témoignages encore des gens
aujourd'hui qui témoigne encore ce matin
j'ai environ une trentaine de messages
qui sont arrivés dans la messagerie
effectif où les familles se retrouvent
dans la demande que l'on que l'on fait
au point du président la pluie si vous
me le permettez je voudrais aussi
apporter une petite précision par
rapport au nombre de défunts on est
actuellement plus de 90000 personnes
décédées il faudrait rajouter quand même
à ce chiffre les personnes qui sont
décédées de la corrida domicile dans les
statistiques sont extrêmement difficiles
à avoir et qui sont estimés à peu près à
douze mille personnes ce qui fait que
rajouter au 90 mais on a dépassé
maintenant les cent mille personnes
décédées de l'aco vide vous êtes en lien
aujourd'hui avec les autorités qu'est ce
qu'elle vous répondre lorsque vous
soumettez ce projet de cérémonie
d'hommage écoutez le lien gelé établi
depuis un an j'ai écrit trois fours
président de la république qui m'a
présenté ses condoléances qui a fait sur
mes trois courriers au ministre des
solidarités la santé monsieur véran le
dit monsieur vers un à qui j'ai
également écrit trop fort qui n'a jamais
eu l'obligeance et la politesse de
répondre mais la dernière interpellation
que je lui ai fait non pas par le
non pas par le bi l'elysée mais que j'ai
diffusé dans un réseau de médias
semblent les avoir interpellé puisque ce
courrier date du 1er mars et le 80
j'avais une réponse de l'elysée est sûre
ce courrier de réponse de l'elysée on
sent qu'il ya une orientation qui se met
en place
dans ce courrier il est précisé que des
réflexions sont en cours pour
l'instauration d'une journée de national
mais pour mai pour en discuter et depuis
un an je demande au président de la
république de ne recevoir pour qu'on
puisse élaborer avec lui une stratégie
par rapport à cette journée d'hommage
quelle quelle journée vous verriez pour
commémorer justement c'est mort du co
vides et quelques alors qu'à
l'emplacement peut-être pour un une
stèle ou en tout cas une plaque
commémorative à l'écouté dans la dans la
demande qu'on a qu'on a fait depuis le
départ il ya deux aspects on avait
demandé qu'un hommage communales
régionales ou départementales soit fait
mais là c'est au niveau des élus locaux
ça commence à se faire ça c'est fait
d'ailleurs hier hier après midi à
levallois perret où effectivement c'est
la première ville de france à avoir mis
en place un hommage aux personnes
décédées de la copie 19 et déjà
remercier encore une fois madame le
maire d'avoir accepté de faire cette
commémoration
pour ce qui me concerne au niveau de ma
petite commune de cormontreuil
je suis en pourparlers avec le maire
pour qui effectivement à nos matches
face à l'or l'hommage que l'on est un
mot niveau national on demande pas la
construction de monuments de 2 5 tonnes
ne sait pas on demande vous savez un
hommage du style qui a été fait à
emmanuel pâtit et c'est très bien de
l'avoir fait pour monsieur emmanuel
pâtit mais bon un hommage tout simple
vous avez quelques minutes de silence le
président de la république peut
prononcer un petit discours on peut se
faire aussi de devant un monument de la
nation et puis bah nous évidemment les
associations pour avoir aussi quelques
mois dire et les familles nous
rejoignent tout à fait dans ce type de
match victime en a nommé samuel pâtit
mais le gouvernement lui leur répond
d'accord mais il faut attendre nous
sommes nous sommes dans le en pleine
pandémie est peut-être attendre la fin
de cette crise sanitaire pour pouvoir
penser à un hommage
qu'est ce que vous en pensez et ça doit
être fait tout de suite pour vous
non non moi j'ai fait venir
mais que ça cesse immédiatement mais
faut pas non plus que ça se fasse dans
15 ans quoi vous savez à titre d'exemple
l'espagne qui c'est qui s'est retrouvé
dans les mêmes conditions que nous avec
les mêmes la même pandémie l'espagne a
fait cet hommage national le 16 juillet
2000 va t il enfin l'hommage de dix
jours rendez vous compte dix jours alors
que nous en france on est encore pas eu
une minute et jusqu'à preuve du
contraire il était dans les mêmes
conditions
alors effectivement à chaque fois on
nous répond qu'effectivement nous sommes
dans une corde ici dans des conditions
difficiles en ce moment ils sont
comprends très bien
mais qu'est-ce qui est ce qui empêche de
se réunir en amont pour justement
pouvoir élaborer et discuter d'une
stratégie à mettre en place
à mon avis pas grand chose on va on va
continuer de suivre cette affaire merci
en tout cas à lionel petit pas pour
votre témoignage ce matin en direct dans
la matinale verte et france merci à vous